donc je m'appelle Fatima Massou je suis
conseillère régional des Hauts-de-France
je suis une retraite du Crédit agricole
où j'étais cadre et donc depuis c'est
mon deuxième mandat au conseil régional
des Hauts-de-France et là je suis
vice-présidente à la Commission à faire
sociale et familiale et je peux dire
aussi que je suis président de Madame de
l'Oise je suis arrivé en France il y a
46 ans c'est un long périple si je puis
dire je viens je suis d'origine
marocaine oui je me suis mariée en 79 et
j'ai deux beaux enfants une fille et un
garçon je suis adhérente à l'UDF d'abord
et au modem depuis 37 ans comment je
suis arrivée à la politique c'était je
puis dire un hasard
mon mari qui était déjà
à l'UDF à l'époque pour dire c'est pas
simplement un modèle mais l'EDF qu'il
manquait une femme pour le conseil
régional pour la parité et puis il m'a
dit est-ce que ça t'intéresse et j'ai
dit pourquoi pas j'ai trouvé l'EDF une
famille une très grande famille
humaniste une famille qui écoute une
famille en même temps qui protège
et une famille qui qui
valorise en même temps parce que je me
suis sentée sentie vraiment bien et je
me suis dit mais c'est ça le but
recherché c'est cette famille là et donc
depuis je l'ai pas quitté donc de l'UDA
au modem jusqu'à maintenant et je suis
pas prête de l'équité comme je l'ai dit
le modem représente pour moi une vraie
famille une famille humaniste une
famille qui prend en compte l'humain
d'abord et ça c'est vraiment très très
important et je pense qu'il y a comme
modem qu'on trouve cette sensibilité